Okay, a lot of people are into these osemic
and weight loss drugs.
If you're on or considering them,
you might wanna watch this.
I don't know if you follow Doctor Andrew Huberman,
but he was just on Joe Rogan
and he was basically saying,
why take osemic
when you can do the same thing naturally
with no side effects
using your bamate?
Turns out humans make GLP1.
GLP1 is stimulated by things like yerba mate, tea,
certain other compounds,
plant compounds
stimulate its release.
But what does it do in the hypothalmus?
It suppresses hunger.
This is the highest,
most concentrated version of yerba latte
I've found on the planet.
And one of the top scientists in the world
when it comes to insulin resistance
did a study on this yerba latte
that I'll be sharing at a meeting in March in Las Vegas.
Is that, um, this yerba latte supplement called Unimate
also increases GLP1.
We found in this experiment we did,
the GLP1 levels went. Went up by.
By about 70% in a fasted states,
which is pretty considerable.
This does the same thing naturally.
No side effects,
no drawbacks.
Whereas ozemphic has gastroparesis,
thyroid cancer
and some crazy
scary side effects.
Plus it just keeps going up in price
and it's getting harder and harder to find.
So this is what I've used to control my blood sugar,
reverse my insulin resistance
and lose weight.
I drink the yerba latte every morning
in place of breakfast.
I Don't feel hungry.
I don't crave food.
Gives me energy and brain clarity.
And then before every meal,
I take this
fiber matrix.
Controls my blood sugar,
carbs, and cholesterol
and is literally the easiest thing in the world.
So instead of doing those MPIC
or those other weight loss drugs
and putting yourself at risk,
try doing it naturally.
I have the discount link that I use on my profile
and it's about $5 a day,
which will actually probably save you money.
And it has a 90 day money back guarantee.